RELENTLESS RED WAVE IN 2022.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE
>> JOINING ME NOW IS ARKANSAS
SENATOR TOM COTTON.
SENATOR, THIS UN SPEECH RUNNING
FROM REPORTERS, TODAY WAS
ANOTHER DISASTROUS DAY FOR BIDEN
ON THE WORLD STAGE.
BUT DOES THAT TRANSLATE INTO ANY
HUMILITY AT HOME?
>> CERTAINLY NOT FROM JOE BIDEN
AND THE DEMOCRATS.
BUT, YOU'RE RIGHT, LAURA, THAT
THIS SPEECH WAS A DISGRACE AT
THE UNITED NATIONS.
JOE BIDEN WALKED INTO THE UNITED
NATIONS WITH A GIANT KICK ME
SIGN ON UNCLE SAM'S BACK IN
PARTICULAR HOW IT RELATES TO
CHINA, HE BENT OVER BACKWARDS TO
APIECE THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY P SAYING WE DON'T WANT A
COLD WAR.
THEY'VE BEEN WAGING A COLD WAR
ON OUR MILITARY AND PEOPLE FOR
DECADES.
THE QUESTION IS NOT WHETHER WE
SEEK ONE THE QUESTION IS WHETHER
WE WILL FIGHT BACK IN IT.
YET JOE BIDEN WOULDN'T EVEN SAY
THE WORD CHINA.
HE'S APPARENTLY EVEN TOO SCARED
TO MENTION CHINA'S NAME IN A
SPEECH ADDRESSED TO THE WORLD'S
LEADERS.
WHAT KIND OF SIGNAL DOES THAT
SEND TO THEM?
WHAT KIND OF SIGNAL DOES IT SEND
TO THE LOADERS OF BEIJING.
I CAN TELL YOU WHAT THEY'RE
DOING RIGHT NOW, THEY ARE
LAUGHING AT JOE BIDEN.
>> LAURA: SPEAK OF, PRESIDENT XI
DECIDES VERY SMARTLY, AS SOMEONE
WHO'S A GROSS VIOLATOR OF HUMAN
RIGHTS, HE'S VERY CLEVER IN
ADOPTING THE LANGUAGE OF THE
WOKE CROWD.
WATCH.
>> WE NEED TO PURSUE
INCLUSIVENESS OVER CONFRONTATION
AND EXCLUSION.
WE NEED TO BUILD A NEW TYPE OF
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS BASED ON
MUTUAL RESPECT, LIBERTY,
JUSTICE.
>> LAURA: WHAT IS EQUITY JUSTICE
AND INCLUSIVENESS MEAN FOR THE
UYGHURS, TAYWAN AND HONG KONG.
>> EXACTLY LAURA.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A MAN IN A
REGIME WHO HAS CRUSHED HONG
KONG'S AUTONOMY AND FREEDOM,
THAT IS STERILE IDEASING
RELIGIOUS AND ETHNIC AUTHORITIES
AND PUTTING THEM IN GOO LOGS,
DESTROYED CHRISTIAN CHOICE
ACROSS CHINA AND LECTURES US,
AND THAT'S BECAUSE JOE BIDEN'S
ADMINISTRATION ACCEPTS THOSE
TERMS.
REMEMBER WHEN TONY BLINKEN WENT
TO A SMUT IN ALASKA AND GOT
LECTURED TO OR WHEN THEY WERE
TOLD WHITE SUPREMACY IS WOVEN
THROUGH THIS NATION.
P IT'S NOT JUST XI.
THEY ALL GO THROUGH FOREIGN
COUNTRIES AND AT THE TIMES THEM
THEY SHOULD NOT LISTEN TO
AMERICA, THEY SHOULD NOT LECTURE
CHINA ABOUT HUMAN RIGHTS BECAUSE
AMERICA HAS ITS OWN PROBLEMS
WITH HUMAN RIGHTS AND THAT'S ALL
BECAUSE OF JOE BIDEN AND HIS
SENIOR CABINET MEMBERS ACCEPTING
THOSE TERMS OF DEBATE ON ANTI
AMERICAN GROUNDS.
>> Laura: SENATOR, IN NATIONAL
REVIEW TODAY THERE WAS A PIECE
ABOUT HOW, IT WAS WELL DONE, HOW
THE REPUBLICANS SHOULD NOT
RESCUE THE DEMOCRATS AT THIS
POINT IN THE 3.5 TRILLION
SPENDING BILL RECONCILIATION
BILL NEGOTIATIONS.
OF DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
GIVEN THIS BIG DEBATE ALSO OVER
THE DEBT CEILING AND WHERE
THAT'S HEADED.
>> WELL, LAURA, YEAH, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO RESCUE THE DEMOCRATS
AND THEIR EFFORTS TO TRY TO
IMPLEMENT THE LARGEST TAX HIKE
IN HISTORY AND SPEND $6 TRILLION
ON THINGS LIKE WELFARE AND
HEALTHCARE FOR ILLEGAL ALIENS OR
DEADBEATS WHO WON'T WORK OR LOOK
FOR WORK OR TAX CREDITS FOR RICH
PEOPLE SO THEY CAN BUY ELECTRIC
CARS.
IF DEMOCRATS WANT TO SPEND
$6 TRILLION ON THE PARTY LINE
BASIS, THEN THE DEMOCRATS CAN
RAISE THE DEBT CEILING THAT MUCH
ON A PARTY LINE BASIS TO COVER
THEIR OWN RECKLESS SOCIALIST
AGENDA.
>> LAURA: WE HAD 19 REPUBLICANS
AGREE TO THAT SO-CALLED
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, WHICH KIND
OF SET THIS ON A BIT OF A GLIDE
PASS, DID IT NOT?
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE THAT MANY
REPUBLICANS VOTE FOR IT IN THE
HOUSE NEXT WEEK AND RIGHT NOW IT
LOOKS LIKE THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN
TOTAL DISARRAY NOT JUST IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL OR THE
BLOWOUT BUT ON THE SIMPLE ACT
THEY'RE TRYING TO KEEP THE
GOVERNMENT FUNDED IF HE CANS
WEEK EVEN THOUGH THEY CONTROL
THE HOUSE, THE SENATE AND WHITE
HOUSE.
REPUBLICANS HAVE CAUTIONED THEM
FOR TWO MONTHS NOW WE WILL NOT
HELP THEM IMPLEMENT THIS
RECKLESS $6 TRILLION SPENDING
PLAN BY RAISING THE DEBT
CEILING.
IT'S TIME THEY TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY, THEY FUNDED THE
GOVERNMENT TO KEEP IT OPEN PAST
NEXT WEEK AND THAT THEY AVOID
ANY KIND OF DEFAULT ON OUR DEBT
NEXT MONTH.
>> WE'LL WATCH